en 2006 je voulais contracter les
assurances et puis
on téléphone important qui était la
première fois m'informer que j'avais
déjà des assurances à cet endroit là on
reste un peu surprise d'écouté non c'est
la première fois que j'ai une voiture et
j'ai ça peut prendre dix ans ça peut
prendre 15 ans et là c'est le cas de
cette dame là c'est le genre de
cauchemar qu'elle vit depuis cette
période là je vous dis allez lire allez
voir le reportage de jacques audiard
charbonneau sur notre site internet pour
comprendre ce que ça peut représenter
notamment pour meriem aubry à qui c'est
arrivé s'est fait voler son identité en
2006 il est encore à ce moment d'amitié
ses empreintes digitales et des
documents pour prouver à la police
qu'elle est bien qu'elle ait bien elles
mêmes entre fois qu'elle épaule à
criminels qui peuvent rechercher dans
certains cas aussi vorace expert en
cyber sécurité d' avec nous ce matin
pour nous en parler depuis 4 heures ce
matin qu'on parle de vous et conduiront
à une liste de questions n'a à peu près
aussi haute que l'édifice de radio
canada
on commence par par ou pour éviter que
les simples citoyens qu'on se fasse
prendre au jeu dans des affaires comme
ça c'est prendre connaissance ou notre
information et les dilapider qu'angers
dilapidé ses ou à qui on la confie
faisait si je peux je prends souvent
l'exemple sont va acheter une simple
paire de bas au magasin et on nous
demande un paquet d'informations
personnelles faisait sap au lieu d'un et
ont fait une transaction au pain achète
un bien on donne un air de l'argent et
on repart avec l'avion pourquoi faudrait
donner notre adresse notre courriel et
nous et tout et tout donc ça c'est pour
des fins de marketing pour une
entreprise donnée
cependant à d'autres fins veut dire
après ce cas qu'on soit on s'en va dans
des salons dont on donne encore une fois
nos informations personnelles pour
espérer de gagner un voyage alors ces
compagnies là vont utiliser celle
informations cumulées
ils vont s'en servait pour les propres
fins de marketing mais souvent après
coup ils vont revendre cette information
là et ça se retrouve dans des lieux ou
dans des endroits des organisations vont
s'en servir à d'autres fins bien encore
le soin pour des fins mercantiles donc
pour faire des transactions financiers
et assez doux vent quelque chose mais
pas plus tard qu'hier j'ai reçu une
invitation par texto un établissement
bancaire qui me disait qu'on avait de
l'argent à prêter
j'avais juste à cliquer oui cela on est
on est on doit être des milliers des
milliers à se voir
et j'ajouterais des centaines de
millions descente c'est un million oui
c'est un phénomène planétaire où les
faussaires sont pas nécessairement ici
au coin de la rue mais bien à l'autre
bout de la planète
de cette façon là ils vont s'y prendre
dit avoir simplement des noms y vend des
adresses ils connaissent police et ils
vont pas ciblé une personne en
particulier ils vont vraiment lancent
ils filaient et espérer de faire cette
pêche au filet l'a ramassé quelques
poissons s'cusez du vaisseau comme son
prénom et après coup bénéficié de cette
pêche là parce que les moyens
technologiques ont explosé les moyens
avec lesquels ils ont pour rejoindre ces
gens-là vulnérables une érable parce que
ce soit des gens qui n'ont pas la
connaissance technique comme vous et moi
et de cette manière là les gens vont
dubaï un semblant de crédibilité
n'encaisse que je lis ou qu'est-ce que
j'en glas parce que souvent ça va tu es
au téléphone mais après coup vont
s'adonner à des bas je prends une chance
peut-être que c'est vrai nom mais pas
des cons et là dessus que je lise en fin
de semaine dans le devoir des
journalistes qui se sont prêtés à
l'exercice et qui ont constaté à quel
point on pourrait faire un portrait de
leur douleur de leurs individus et
plusieurs d'entre eux maintenant
utiliser un gestionnaire de mots de
passe dans mon dans mon téléphone ou
dans mes applications
est ce que c'est quelque chose vous
recommander ça absolument aujourd'hui un
gestionnaire de mots de passe c'est
quand même c'est quand même on met
toutes nos oeufs dans le même panier
mais par contre on peut gérer jeu sympa
ni sur celle avantage cependant si le
jeu serait le moteur devient compromis
elles ont accès à tous c'est ça qui est
le gîte le risque mais dans cette
gestion de risque de jerry sands is ce
un mot de passe 2 300 morts jeudi on a
plus en plus à chaque combat visiter on
veut que ce soit différent chaque fois
et voilà un rap de retenir ce nom et
surtout ce cas qu'on veut mettre un mot
de passe différent à chacun des sites où
on va aller porter cette information là
ça devient un petit peu difficile à
gérer donc le gestionnaire de mots de
passe lui va aider certainement à garder
un mot de passe différent et surtout à
garder quand est ce qu ont accédé au
moteur au site en question avec les mots
de passe différents donc dans un exemple
vous avez un site auquel vous allez
faites vous avez fait des transactions
nous avait changé de l'information le
site deviendrait compromis comme on a vu
dans le passé que je donne un exemple
facile avec lui linkedin dans le modèle
des affaires allemand des enfants
beaucoup de gens 4 58 ans a reçu une
lettre de fossa et 10 ans des voix si on
connaît votre moto c'était le vrai mot
de passe qui était décrypter de la base
de données volées 4,5 en vain et après
ça des gens on se sont faites et ben oui
ça doit être crédit serré à lyon le mot
parce que seul moi je connais qui ont
mis dans la base de données donc églises
beaucoup de gens m'ont approché y
croyait que le système le pc étaient
infectées avaient été investis de gens
comme ça alors que cela provenait
justement d'un autre situation
complètement extérieur donc c'est pour
ça que je suis content avec des journées
et prix l'occasion de dire on donne pas
la caisse qui est par défaut de notre
protection d'equifax mais on leur
demande à 5,1 ça va donner un certain
répit cependant je crois que les forçats
vont s'adapter là aussi il n'est pas
impossible que l'on voit l'information
qu'elle soit utilisée dans 6 à 10 6
cependant l europe a la même valeur sur
le marché pour être revendus parce
qu'elle aurait été à ce moment le
surveiller pendant toutes ces années
en deux mots si notre établissement
bancaire musique issue gouvernement nous
écrit ou peint pas qui nous dit de
changer nos mots de passe on fait
surtout de suite ça brouille les cartes
pour un pour l'autre de changer les mots
de passe est une chose mais en même
temps de prendre connaissance pourquoi
faut changer c'est une autre chose qu'il
faut pas oublier une chose
un détail les actions financières le
gouvernement n'écrit pas par courrier
les narines ou jean billy eckstine
exactement ça rentre par la boîte à
malle la bonne vieille poste il ya
quelque chose que le savez monsieur voir
nous n'allons pas mieux comme ça écoutez
merci beaucoup d'études voir j'espère
que ça va être utile à tout le monde au
dessus qui pour empêcher que ça nous
arrive de se faire voler son identité
merci le plaisir et bonne journée